spend any time on manifestation Tick
Tock you'll notice that each manifesting
Guru has their own magical combination
of words that's supposed to lead to
health and prosperity use this one
affirmation to manifest money within 24
hours I want you to comment down below
if you manifest any sort of money within
24 hours I'm assured to you that it will
work I am magnetic to money money can't
get enough of me I am magnetic to Money
Money cannot get enough of me
visualize yourself as a magnet drawing
in abundance and wealth because you're a
beautiful being and you deserve to live
an enriching fulfilling life I guess
I'll have to go check my bank account to
see if that worked I don't have very
high hopes